grâce à ces ma fille
là par exemple je vais dessiner des deux
côtés comme ça je peux utiliser la même
qui valent gauche à droite et de droite
à gauche
[Musique]
oh
quand on prend les photos en tout cas
sur mon iphone et convenez en mode photo
il ya une petite bande on voit toutes
les photos et si on passe le doigt
dessus on voit l'animation parce qu'on
voit toutes les photos les unes après
les autres donc on peut savoir si ça
fonctionne je suis dans la caisse
d'animation alors bon tu gagnes pour ma
fille et donc on sait
le boxon voilà ça c'est ma fille
je lui ai dit de faire un décor dessiné
ensuite j'ai une tête de bonhomme corps
des bras et j'ai tout décider tout de
les couper
apprendre à placer sa sur des porcs et
je veux aider de bouger
le personnage de type un tout petit peu
un tout petit peu un tout petit peu elle
a très bien compris elle faisait l'un
des petits déplacements ce qui fait que
c'est très joli à regarder ça ça bouge
de manière très très souple je peux vous
montrer temps alors ça c'est la boîte de
certaines choses que j'anime aimons par
exemple j'ai eu des signes et une
dizaine de tours eiffel j'aime beaucoup
faire les lettres
je les gars mais je préférais me
dessiner charpy
comme ça on met story bonne voie la r21
géré dessiner le personnage plein de
fois où je le remplace et à chaque fois
il a une idée avance un petit peu il
peut bouger les bras les jambes et c'est
aussi c'est un petit oiseau dans le fond
je fais deux positions de dessins que je
découpe qu'il faut la même taille avec
les ailes vers le haut lien avec les
ailes vers le bas et à presse en gros je
fais de jeu prend deux photos et que des
messages vers le bas des deux photos qui
saveurs aux jeux puis en boucle on peut
bouger les gens comme ça j'ai les
remplacer il ya une partie
il ya un élément les jambes sont comme
ça est un élément où les gens sont comme
ça
donc en faisant ça ait un changement ça
donne vraiment l'impression de marche
alors que ses traits extrêmement riche
et moi ce qui me plaît beaucoup c'est
qui c'est une invention de à chaque
image est un problème à régler et je ne
trouve de la solution par exemple il
faut faire disparaître un personnage on
fait une petite fondre dans le décor et
va se glisser en dessous a passé ça a
l'air vraiment banal est minimal mais
quand votre esprit un 100% dedans ce
quelqu'un ça devient tout misé tout
progrès minuscule devient un problème
majeur
à régler mais d'une façon positive c'est
à dire que on ressent une une forme de
joie quand la trouver la solution
au départ il faut pas mettre la barre
trop haute il faut c'est trouver les
solutions soi même même si c'est pas le
meilleur
plutôt que de s'arrêter et d'aller
demander à quelqu'un d'animation on
pense que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement c'est minutieux et on
pense c'est tellement ça prend tellement
de temps et c'est tellement ça demande
tellement de courage mais en réalité si
on fait un pas avec un personnage et
qu'on le voit on est tellement contents
qu'on a envie de faire un autre pas y
aller piano pas et on arrive à travers
sept canaux directs
une fois qu'on a décidé de le faire faut
aller jusqu'au bout
était en cours et ça c'est vraiment j'ai
pas grand
beaucoup de conseils à donner quand on
me demande qu'est-ce que comment je
devrais faire il faut vraiment
ça y est de règle il faut commencer et
il faut terminer mais la deuxième règle
est encore plus importante que la
première
si vous terminez pas
vous serez jamais si c'est raté au
réussit donc on n'apprend rien ceci
c'est raté on apprend beaucoup de choses
même peut-être plus que si c'est réussi